en berna suiza una muestra de
solidaridad con ucrania mientras el
presidente volodymyr selenski piden más
compromiso a las empresas good food good
life
buena comida buena vida este es el lema
de nestlé la empresa que se niega a
abandonar rusia incluso ahora cuando hay
amenazas de rusia a otros países
europeos
en aras de se le anunció previamente la
prohibición de sus productos estrella en
rusia pero sigue operando en el país
suministrando productos de primera
necesidad como alimentos para bebés y
cereales y manteniendo abiertas sus
siete fábricas locales dicen que es
porque deben suministrar productos
esenciales para satisfacer las
necesidades de la población local pero
para nestlé moscú también representa el
2 por ciento de su facturación casi 1800
millones de dólares y tienen 7 mil
empleados su decisión de permanecer
abierta ha suscitado críticas en
internet bajo el hashtag boicot a nestlé
se han compartido imágenes de un
logotipo de nestlé secuestrado el
emblemático nido está vigilado por un
pájaro que lleva un brazalete nazi con
una zeta
en francia protestas contra las empresas
que siguen operando en rusia muy es un
gigante de la distribución con marcas
como decathlon georgetown
el grupo está presente en rusia desde
hace unos 20 años pero para muller el
mercado ruso es enorme sólo se genera en
el país más del 10 por ciento de su
tonelaje mundial la corporación afirma
que al igual quienes le tienen la
responsabilidad de proporcionar
alimentos a los rusos